all right introduce our characters our
actors here is John Bradley
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
next up we have Rose Leslie Christopher
Kit Harington got sophie Turner in the
house Natalie Dormer we had a fellow
named george RR martin
[Applause]
Maisie Williams Rory McCann Gwendoline
Christie Nikolaj coster-waldau Pedro
Pascal
and finally our excellent moderator
Craig Ferguson
[Applause]
thanks very much indeed for saying that
person who's not really telling the
truth I'm very happy to be here everyone
thank you David and Dan for introducing
me last after these people camp out all
night to see these people and then at
the very end me I thought you understood
dramatic structure it's very nice to be
a welcome to San Diago
which as we know is this far south as
South goes remember that it's from
season two I thought you guys knew about
that welcome to the big one now of
course we're all here to celebrate Game
of Thrones I understand that many of you
people today will know this show better
than I do
matter of course these people do and
certainly you will I know there are
people who are fluent and Dothraki out
there right now but remember we're all
in the same sight
how often do you get do you get to see
each other any point there all these
different worlds that you exist do you
guys ever get to hang out together in
the bar in the bar is there a bar like
somewhere that isn't in the title
sequence that pop so if you know the
right place to go it's like it's like
the Star Wars bar but it's Game of
Thrones but I can imagine probably as
the White Walkers and stuff the thing is
you are I'm surprised to see you here
Rory given your what happened and you
know as you were left on the
mountainside yeah well I'm still sore I
can't believe I'm here just yeah things
weren't looking too good the last time I
saw myself so I thought he got off
lightly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
nasty [ __ ] which one like me I believe
I've been pooped between your very very
uncomfortable
[Laughter]
George may I ask you a question yes when
you began the creation of all of the
this this world of Westeros and all of
the attendant stories that happened
there and did you envisage anyone to
look like these we would does it look
like the world you first know of does it
feel like it well more or less but of
course not exactly I mean I started this
in 1991 and the show I didn't even have
my first meeting with David and Dan
until 2007 I believe it was so there
were like 16 years before the show was a
twinkle in anyone's eye and I had very
strong pictures of what Westeros looked
like and what the characters look like
but these people have brought the
characters to like you know amazingly
does it affect does it affect you right
and since when you watch the show and
you continue to write there's a there's
a new does it inform what you do not not
not really because I do have those 16
years that sort of took deep root before
the show came along I sometimes it gets
a little tricky but the show is the show
and the books are the books and I
already keep them separate I know a few
of the actors have read the books but
many of them don't
where can I ask which actors here were
were fine where we're reading the books
before they became cast members on the
show is that something that you all do
or no or not as the case may be it
certainly isn't a prerequisite obviously
they are you guys clearly were fans of
the of the books right when did you
first come in contact with them when we
first we hit the books years ago eight
years ago that's a long time it is a
long time and and how did you manage to
get it going with because it clearly
this is something that costs a great
deal of money
to put together how do you manage to
talk HBO on this first we had to talk
George into it right and sorry because
some of you probably heard the story
before but we had a very long lunch with
George where we told them what we wanted
to do with the adaptation and and we had
a 3-hour talk at the very end of it
George said okay okay who is Jon Snow's
real mother and there was a very long
pause and I looked at Dan and Dan looked
at me and we threw out a guess and he
kind of he didn't say yes or no they
sort of nodded and then he let us take
the show who is Jon Snow his real mother
this is smell good spirits never mind
all right
well that's good and so you shoot most
of the time and you all shouldn't
Belfast all the time is that what you
make everything now we shoot in Belfast
you're through the entire shooting
season but we also have other foreign
locations which vary from year to year
this year it's going to be Croatia in
Spain in past years we've been in in
Malta and Morocco and Iceland and the
subject matter of the show can be from
time to time quite controversial is that
something that you know sometimes you go
to a conservative area perhaps where
they aren't happy when they find out
it's you guys filming there that
happened this year yes
lost a location I feel like though if
the bible thumpers stopped something the
bible for a minute and read it they
would see there's just as much incest
tumor we had we lost a location this
year to a man who did not want his
property to be involved with porn of
Thrones so please remember the views
expressed by David and dannan nowhere
represent my own views and for legal
reasons yes so whose may I ask by show
of hands who still left alive and the
cast
let's see yes so we've got about halfway
do you if I may ask first the actors who
are still with us does it concern you
when you receive the scripts that you
know this may be it does it worry you
that you yeah I mean some of us know
roughly what happens in the books to our
characters but I know that daivam down
have killed characters that are still
alive in the books and vice versa so we
never really know so I just suck up to
David the key lesson for the actors has
never asked for raise seems like right
now I think what we're going to do I
believe is that we have some new cast
members that you wanted to talk about as
well is that right sure yeah yes we big
season coming up whole bunch of new
characters and we thought they would say
hello to you themselves so yeah or me I
guess
[Applause]
I'm Sebastian
and I'm playing Christine he will rub
the world dream of being a part of this
so for me it's a night to think Arsenal
circus people
[Music]
[Music]
incredible production a completely
stoked bring it up
my name is Enzo Jillette see and when
playing yessir I am coughing with
excitement moves epic my character
weapons
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
some of the characters that you'll be
getting attached to and which die
horribly over the next 18 months I don't
really want to take up a whole lot of
time from this panel today not giving
you a chance to talk because obviously
there are a great many members of the
cast here so rather than me talking I
want to kind of throw it to the floor
quite quickly so that we can get as many
questions as possible for the fans who
have waited as you say overnight so can
we start putting that together right
away and when you come up to ask first
please identify yourself and speak
coherently loudly yes yes David say if
you do us a favor and don't ask us
what's gonna happen next season oh yeah
no obviously there'll be no spoilers
here and also if you do know what
happens in the books and then you want
to ask questions about stuff that have
you know it hasn't reached that point in
the series yet grow up and don't all
right
that's right very good everyone we're
all friends we're all unsullied in a way
I know I am all right sir may I ask your
name and my students my name is Rick and
my question is for mr. Martin as the
creator of this universe I'm wondering
if there's any of the many gods or
deities that you most closely associate
yourself with and if I may suggest one
perhaps the many-faced God because you
kill with utter impunity I have plenty
of unity no I don't think I choose any
one God over the other and my reputation
for killing is is exaggerated as I as I
like to point out that David and David
and Dan are far bloodier than I am and
they've killed a number of characters
who are still alive in the books so you
know I mean I may only be the second
ranked murderer here on the panel but no
III I think religion is an important
part of the world and should be depicted
but I'm not about to endorse one
Westerosi religion is true over the
others there you are George is the
second best killer on the panel
apparently yes hi my name is Lila hi
Lila
are you - rocky you've got lovely hair
thank you maybe my question is for Kit
Harington he's got lovely here even
though you know nothing Jon Snow
it's true it's true I wanted to ask you
what do you do to prepare for your roles
on the wall you know before battle
scenes also in the freezing cold and
just what do you do beforehand to
prepare I think I think with with
Thrones it's weird a lot of the workers
-
for you before you even get there and I
think a big part of that for me is
costume because we have such wonderful
costumes on this show that when I find
put it on and it's got a certain weight
to it the certain sort of gives us
certain gravity that I I kind of it's
weird I'm about to go back and start my
first day on Monday which is really
exciting and I've got great scene but
it's it's odd I've just had my hair dyed
and everything and I get back into that
costume and it's very sort of very
grounding that's kind of how I how I
kind of fall into John snow it's not
very exciting the hair products right
yeah there are many many hair products
that's the same of John Andrews who are
north of the wall with you as well you
guys are you working in hair because is
it always that cold that do you have to
act cold in those that no I mean we were
we were in you know the northern part of
Iceland for the majority of season two
and three and so though it was
absolutely freezing so there's acting
involved when we were cold um but uh but
no I mean there were times when we were
using like minus 40 but we had these
thermals underneath the costume and so
that definitely helped and then you had
a big fat cloak on um but no it is it's
beautiful and it was mesmerizing being
in Iceland but it kind of cold is it
kind of wakes you up and make sure that
you yeah I don't view it at all they say
for you
yeah I think that what this show really
excels in is putting the actors into the
same environment as the characters would
find themselves if the characters about
cold we tend to be that cold and when
when we were in Iceland especially we
thought that we were walking on the
ground we were actually walking on five
feet of compacted snow so if you get my
costume which weighs a fair amount on
its own put me in it which which you
know he's never going to help anything
and then in have me charging across a
glacier being chased by a camera on a
quad bike chances are that by the end of
the day I've been driven into the ground
like a tent peg and you know people say
oh yeah those costumes must really
keep you warm and they do but from the
neck down and as an actor your tool
deprived me expression is your face is
your tool which not in America it means
something different here and I
understand I understand I'll reiterate
Craig's sentiment grow up but you find
your performance completely compromised
because you can't be subtle at all
because your face is freezing up
literally freezing up and at minus 35
you're at work and you think okay if I'm
ever this cold again in my life
something's gone fairly badly wrong all
right there you go may I ask yes your
name hi my name is Jacob hi Jacob
what's your question well I have so many
questions for all of you yeah but you
want to get one big one is but my
questions for the masterminds behind the
show George David and Dan as the pacing
of the show has really sped up and
caught up with almost to where a dance
Dragons is um how will you go forward
planning this throughout the next few
seasons and years as will it surpass the
books as far as the timeline or which
one will end first are we gonna wait
Jacob it's a fantastic question and we
can't answer without telling you what's
gonna happen so do you and I do you
should we give Jacob an alternate
question because yeah yeah you can ask
one of the many other questions that you
said you had so many questions Matt you
guys the one we can't answer oh man well
how is it working in all of the
different sets and how do you manage to
bring together all these different
stories twisting and turning into one
great arc that just has an epic feel to
it and it's as a real world it's a whole
world Wow yeah how do you do that yeah
you do it
it's in Georgia's mine it all started
enjoyed his brain how many years ago
George 30 years ago 1991 when it George
30 say that were you three years ago
yeah and you know those characters every
single character sitting up here at this
table started out in some dark region of
George's mind okay George you named all
the places in Westeros why do they all
sound a little bit like artisanal cheese
farms you get King's Landing
all of them sound like to make a fairly
decent cheese I like cheese from I don't
know you know the naming things in
fantasy is very hard you know I been re
do we have Westeros but we've recently
came out with a map book where they
wanted me to draw maps of the entire
world and we have the world of Ice and
Fire coming in October which is like a
concordance and you know I'm drying up
maps for places like thousands of miles
to the east where the story will never
go and I'm I'm just running out of names
well yeah the pointy mountains the the
the the sharp and a misty mint no
Tolkien used to misty mountains the the
really sees now you know you know you do
the best you can and you're doing very
well George I didn't mean you to think
that was criticizing yes it looks like
we have an emissary from another Kingdom
yeah hello okay this question better be
for me you know it I'm Erik this is
Angie for someone say do you know why
the oli world hates the Lannisters are
questions for Pedro can you describe the
process preparing for the big battle and
episode not hey you guys look amazing by
the way yeah you look very good may I
say I think about if I speak about with
most of us here Petra how delighted we
are to see you intact
[Applause]
um the HBO team set me up with a master
of wushu very early in the process
actually and put me into some training
with a guy named master who in Los
Angeles and then of course I was on set
in Belfast doing extensive rehearsals
with Cece Smith and the fight team and a
half Thor the the other actor and I had
an amazing double I mean come on guys I
could ask the same actually of Nikolaj
Gwendolyn and Rory actually and and that
you're all a lot of fight scenes a lot
of very complicated and difficult we can
find scenes did you do that before the
show is it's a skill you landed in drama
school or is it are you actually sore
day in your life to it when I was about
three four months old found I developed
an aptitude with it and then this part
came up and it seemed like my whole life
it's a nurse they trained us really
intensively we work with amazing amazing
stunt team all of us who are very
patient and deal with us with a great
deal of humour particularly me who can
be a bit slow it takes a while for it to
sink in and you work hard but it's
always with the goal that you want it to
be as brilliant as it possibly can be
and they facilitate that yes yes I mean
I had a great teacher once called Dave
Hockaday who was just amazing and for
there was years ago he's in Leeds now
leads yes you need a sword and they need
a sword yeah you do but I think I was
just gonna say cuz I was those two
fights what Gwen and Rory did and it was
just wasn't that just amazing there was
extraordinary
I mean I I didn't go to drama college I
didn't learn sword fighting but I grew
up in Glasgow and we we don't use swords
we use a thing called a chip yes
it's like a sword you know it's got
needles at the end of the stick
seems to do the trick yeah I spoke to
Gwen after your fight she was in tears
sorry she beat me up I did
[Laughter]
can I ask maybe I don't for the dynamic
Natalie and Sofia you you're jealous of
the of the swordplay do you ever wish
you could get a little more in the way
of kind of brutal killing action going
on isn't she adorable yeah I am I really
I was talking to Gwen just backstage
about her fight look I'm a massive Rob
Roy that movie that there's a fighting
Rob Roy great fight it's a fantastic
sword fighting Leone was really into
swords when I was in my 20s so as Margie
I did get a bit frustrated when I first
started but she's proven to have other
weapons
I was just complimenting and Gwen on
that fight because you can count on one
hand I think when I watch films and see
plays I'm always really interested in
the authenticity of the violence and
that's what's great about Game of
Thrones violence is that it's disturbing
because it's so real and accurate
naturalistic and I thought it was a
particularly amazing fight and I asked
about the sword holding moment and you
said that Cece um the stunt guy who
created the fight actually does love the
film Rob Roy and had nixed that moment
of holding the sword and hand bleeding
it was a really nice nod and a nice
reference I thought it's an outstanding
fight we rate Natalie we're the ones who
ripped off Rob Roy not Cece we stole
that moment from sorry Holmes to clarify
we're not supposed to tell anybody about
that yes for legal reasons they're just
kidding it's the moment that lead decent
liam neeson grabs the sword and we
totally stole it and you weren't
supposed to tell anyone that
well this swordplay is excellent and I
may ask basic could you point out on
Rory where the heart is hey you still
got it
all right good afternoon good afternoon
mr. Martin good
tonight cast of Game of Thrones my name
is Gerald and I'm here representing the
Hall H posse my question is for mr.
Martin and the cast mr. Martin you
populated the world of Westeros with
many unique wonderful and terrifying
people when writing about the characters
has when what about the triumphs and
tribulations of the characters has that
helped you discover something about
yourself or help you overcome a
real-life challenge and if so can you
share that with your fans and to the
cast which cast in the show is most like
you and why that's like five questions
man yeah that's a lot of questions
you know you draw on yourself
particularly for the viewpoint
characters you may base them on people
you know on figures from history on your
imagination but ultimately to make a
character come alive when you're writing
from inside them you have to delve into
yourself fortunately you know I'm large
I contain multitudes as I think what
Whitman said always steal from the best
so a lot of different characters can can
be pulled from inside one and I I'm
different from many of the characters
I've never been a an exiled princess or
a dwarf or an eight-year-old girl but I
think the common humanity unites all
these characters and we all we all have
that in common that's what I try to draw
on when creating characters you student
has to be George you study Europe oh yes
yeah because it seems like there are
echoes of a law of European you know the
wall and a lot of the you know the way
that the world is put together is very
like you know from I guess early Europe
you know and is it something that
fascinated you a lot of a lot of Game of
Thrones are stolen from your Scottish
history I know I know
bloody and dispiriting history that you
have there up in Scotland yeah I I live
in LA
[Laughter]
I love the the black dinner and the
Glencoe massacre those for the red
wedding good times all right
why we have a crew
we have a crew hi my name is John and I
know kid yeah my question is for rose
and Kate what do you think was going on
to the heads of your characters when
they saw each other again at the Battle
of the wall that's that is a great
question and a brilliant outfit brother
that's great well then I am I don't know
I think it was an important moment for
us I think it was a I think what was
what I wanted to try and capture is that
he's just very happy to see her again
really at the heart at the horse of it
after everything that's happened he
doesn't really care in some ways if that
arrow is loosed and he dies he got to
see her one last time and I think that
that moment is obviously broken with
what happens next but I am yeah I think
it's a beautiful moment for him it's
quite profound silence there's a silence
there we wanted to get I think but I
agree thanks man it is very - I mean I
think that there was that silence are
you talking about that it became very
profound and I think certainly for
Ygritte throughout season four you know
she was she was on a ruthless mission
and she was gonna get her own back when
Jon Snow and I don't think she at all
anticipated just how much she loved him
I'm just that hesitation seeing him
again completely through her and I don't
think she foresaw that at all and of
course that was you know her her last
kind of breath as it were but um but ya
know it was a very beautiful moment and
we didn't really want to discuss much
about it on the day when we shot it we
kind of just wanted to see how it would
organically kind of slow yes gentlemen
in alarmingly ordinary clothing thank
you find out early and the rest of the
cast
I wonder who you questions questions for
George okay the one thing I've always
wanted to ask you for years is um Hodor
Oh Dora that's it Oh d'Or yes oh now I
feel a little more comfortable well
hello to you hi what's your question
girlfriend hi my name is Dan my question
is for Dan and Dave mmm
now that Stannis has arrived at the wall
can we look forward to more scenes
developing his character first Stannis
the Manas I think we can say we can say
yes oh yeah in violation of our early
yes we can say yes you can cuz I was
gonna say that then you would say well
he's that we can say he's a fascinating
character that's amazingly well drawn by
Steve and Elaine and we will be taking
advantage of both the character and the
actor in the season I'd be careful about
that woman is with them though she
worried so he doesn't worry you
she has her moments she worries me I
don't think she's all about being good
at all or any of us really Oh door yes
sir yeah my question is for George
I was wondering with the show getting
close to catching up with the books what
would you say to fans who were planning
to stop watching the show once it gets
into content from book 6 and 7 so that
they can experience the story in its
true form at would you encourage us to
just watch the show anyways or would you
encourage us to wait until the books
comes out and then watch the show yes I
encourage everyone to watch the show
we'd like to announce we're here to ask
you to stop watching the show
until we're ready for you to start again
I do also encourage people to read the
books reading the books was good you
know that I the question of so you can
experience the story in its true form
yeah it's kind of a loaded one you know
I've said a couple times in posts the
riddle how many children does Scarlett
O'Hara have Scarlett O'Hara
has three children in Margaret
Mitchell's novel Scarlett O'Hara has one
child in the classic movie of Gone with
the Wind how many children does Scarlett
O'Hara have what's the true story of
course the true story is Scarlett O'Hara
has no children because she never
existed
she's a fictional character and there
are two wonderful classic ways of
telling a story and you know that maybe
the situation that is the situation with
the show is the show and the book is the
book you know who did Robb Stark marry
did she marry
did he she marry a noblewoman from
volantis name to Lisa who died at the
red wedding or did she marry did he
marry a woman named Jane Westerling
who's still alive and will be seen in
the prologue of winds of winter is one
true is one not true well you know how
many children did Scarlett O'Hara have
[Applause]
for now so my question is I guess open
for anybody if you guys could kind of
walk us through what the production
process is like because we're assuming
that the shooting schedules all over the
place so how is it kind of moving from
episode to episode and going back and
forth you shoot out of sequence I
presume right everything's sure we do
yeah we shoot it as if it's a 10-hour
movie so so we sometimes last year we
shot scenes from the tenth episode in
the first week and we shoot in three
different countries this year
Ireland Spain and Croatia five different
directors shooting two episodes each and
the actors have to come and travel all
over the place so it's in the way it's
called cross boarding which is just a
expression meaning that you know
basically wherever is the best time for
a scene to shoot it's going to shoot and
and to separate units the dragon unit
the wolf unit is really boring stuff I'm
sorry I mean I think it's a valid
question to the actors who are who are
playing characters who are now deceased
in the series how did you shoot your
death scenes in sequence did you have to
come back and shoot you know other
scenes after you had been had your head
squeezed in your eyes popped out my um
for example my very first day on set was
the cell scene with Tyrion it was the
you know my big scene yeah and I was
petrified
thanks a lot David it was my first day
on set it was my first day in full
costume and III don't know how the hell
I got through it to be honest with you
it was it was it was pretty
nerve-wracking but Peter made it really
easy and alle cos the director took care
of me but it was totally and from that
point I mean it it it sort of like was
diving in right at the gate and and that
was my that was my intro into the season
and then we were all over the place the
fight sequence came a little towards the
end what about you Rory and was that
your story as well I was lucky I think
my last days were like the last days
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's an unusual thing normally it's
all Hagel to pickle tea but there the
fight and the death was that was at the
end
luckily I'm working with Maisie and she
knew what was going on because I get
very confused
was that your story that you shoot the
death scene towards the end of the shoot
yeah yes like scheduling and production
work very lovely in that respect because
they my final day
on the show was the time what was the
scene when I died in kids arms and so
luckily having shot that I didn't then
have to you know turn off in two days
time and be like hi I'm Patrick that was
yeah that was my final day and then that
was it thank you
yes yes I since most serious questions
have been asked I wanted to ask Wendelin
what was it like to bide the hounds ear
off and so Rory doesn't feel left out
what was it like to uh downstairs cake
gran downstairs downstairs kick that's
just the sort of language we will not
tolerate hares oh yeah
what was it like Rory yeah but here's a
little secret
did we do that I think the idea was to
put a strap in between your knees or
when you were crawling and that one move
I could take our right good run at ER
but we'd still keep her safe we didn't
do that Oh mr. memmer you you went when
she punched me and that with the wrist
connections going on there
between the legs it was horrible
when she bit my year second-best mate
well it kind of tickled to be honest get
off me yes no sir
hello hi my name is Jason good for you
alright so I recently read an article
where kit harington said he wanted to
see more male nudity in the show
[Music]
[Applause]
so first of all what are you gonna do
about that and second what what was
second cuz I'm gonna go what does
everyone else think we can throw it open
for general discussion to the panel
would be like to see more male nudity
right now on the show
[Applause]
equality I'm very aware anything I say
right now is being listened to by the
man at that end of the table so I'm
gonna shut up and not say a thing so I
don't have to get my kit off next season
see to fully exam you see you can't
really lose with me because no careful
what you wish for few zone to public
pressure the good thing about me and
male nudity is that everybody is served
because it'll still get the boob count
up
everybody wins I was about yes madam I
want to ask the whole cast dragons are
direwolf ah let's begin at the very end
with you then John let's start with you
writes dragons or dire wolves and I'm
after gonna I'm gonna have to be loyal
to my storyline be loyal to my my
compadre and say die walls of course I
was same for you I'm going to disagree
and go for dragons what
I'm shocked get doubles sofa
dials dials George you have a favorite
pass dials easier to kill snakes
[Applause]
gentlemen do you have a favorite no
don't play favorites fair enough
all right there you are I hear that the
Dragons are easier to work with
right yeah they do what you tell them
yeah oh yeah see what you mean yeah but
no well nevermind uh yeah yes sir
howdy uh quick question so obviously the
book and the show don't always go hand
in hand but there was a major character
reveal that sort of happens at the end
of book 3 and I was just wondering and
talking about can't talk about it
blatant violation of the rules get out
get out I know we can't obviously I
can't help you with that
somebody nip down there and stab him
[Laughter]
Yeah right yes hello hi hi what are you
doing oh it's on you get the wrong panel
oh I do what I can't write wait one you
guys are all amazing and thank you for
sitting here and asking answering inane
questions from us all day but my
question is for Sophie because I feel
like Sansa Stark gets a lot of crap that
she does not deserve
um Manta is badass and awesome and I've
been annoying my roommates all weekend
like teen sand singing all over the
place so I was just wondering if you
could talk a little bit how you came to
you envision her journey from where she
started to where she'd end up at the end
of this season which was just amazing
and I think even I'm sorry for saying
this George a little bit of a step up
from oh when you're stopping the other
guy stop her as well when your dad I
never really liked when I was like 13 I
didn't really think okay this is the way
my characters gonna go and it's gonna be
great when I started yeah I didn't have
a plan for her I just kind of it sounds
really gross and pretentious but I kind
of grew with her as an actress while she
grew as a character and then I mean it's
really down to the writing of both
George and you know David damn Bryan
cogman Vanessa and when I got the
scripts through for season four it was
like it was such a relief because for
the past like three seasons
she's been deceiving with the facade of
her former self for so long and it was
such a relief for me to finally be able
to like shed the skin and become this
somewhat manipulator that she actually
is from being you know at court with
Cersei and Tywin and she finally gets
reveal herself it was freaking awesome
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my questions for George
everyone's asked about how the fight
between Brienne and the hand felt for
the characters and the actors but how
did that separation from the book feel
for you well it was a great scene you
know that
David and Dan have have and the other
writers Bryan cogman was mentioned he
deserves a lot of credit to have added
some scenes that are not in the book in
part because there are no viewpoint
characters present in every season that
I've loved the first season the the
scene between Robert and Cersei where
they discuss their marriage not in the
books but a terrific scene second season
in the Blackwater episode the wonderful
scene and Wood bran confronts the hound
and the brothel terrific scene and I put
this the the battle in the same in the
same category it was just great
television and it was it was terrific to
watch you know the things I'm Warner for
the most part the scenes that didn't
make it you know I've been pretty open
since before she's someone that I wish
we had three more episodes of season it
would of course killed David and Dan I
realized that but you know it would give
us parity with some other HBO shows and
enabled us to include some of the stuff
that gets cut but there's some stuff
that gets added particularly when it's
as great as that scene I love it can I
can I ask you all a question while we're
here because there's been a lot of
questions for George obviously about
their separation with the books and the
shoes how many of you perhaps bye-bye
applause have read the books so let's go
another way how many of you by applause
have not read the books
[Applause]
how many of you know the story of
Westeros five-plus I think probably all
of you and I think that the information
is interesting that I'm watching the the
separation of the two I find quite
fascinating this is there a is there a
loyalty between the people who have read
the books do you feel you're more
advanced and more a part of the world
than the people who have not I mean
we'll see you so genuine question III
wonder if you are are you
I'm leaving San Diego today yes Jack
Sparrow captain captain captain DJ
person line for the Pirates v panel
right here waiting outside anyways this
goes right into my question more like a
praise I'd like to give a round of
applause to you guys for doing I mean
how many times have we said the book is
so much bloody better pretty much
because we want to prove that we can
read but mostly we say that all the time
for the first time ever I've never heard
one person say that this show is just as
brilliant give a round of applause these
guys this amazing work what you've all
done to do that here you're a much
deeper man than you are in the pirate
movies if I may say I am NOT drunk right
now so gun that goes in then I get a
little shortchange on it but reason I
look like this is because tonight there
is a game of Thrones costume party on a
pirate ship wanted to divide all of you
your names were already on the list
everybody in the whole year invited you
to come have ivana run bring me run more
two men party dot-com tonight hope to
see you fat thanks thanks and when
you're stopping the other two give him a
quick stab when you're done as well
oh hello hi hi I'm Catherine and this
question is for my beloved sophie Turner
in the episode of Joffrey's wedding you
and Tyrion seem to starts getting kind
of close and I was wondering what you
think
Sansa antarians relationship now that
they are separate
I think it's devastating he was my other
half we loved each other so much you can
feel the love but they really did
actually begin to have this genuine bond
and trust with each other and it was
just getting kind of beautiful and then
in the spirit of Game of Thrones they
cut that off but I think I mean I would
like in the future for them to be
reunited at some point because I think
they'd be a pretty awesome like power
couple in the future like the new
Brangelina but I think yeah it was a
really lovely relationship and she was
finally beginning to trust him and love
him not in that way but you know it's
just a person and they were really on
each other's team I love your outfit
what mess even a lovely dress no no I
didn't ask you a question I just said
your dress was nice that's right off you
go hello that's a nice outfit too I
wanted to thank all of you for coming
you guys are my favorite characters
literally everyone who's up there my
question is for Maisie aria has had to
change her identity to survive so many
times like re and nan and now that she's
finally on her own like going where she
wants to go how do you feel that she's
still attached to who she is as of stark
or do you think that she's someone new
entirely or how do you play that she is
no one
[Applause]
by the way I believe I believe Sean
Benson tone anybody seen guys the joke
man he's fine
yes sir thank you so much for bringing
what a wonderful world into everyone's
lives and why don't you stop looking for
benjin yes King yes engine start here
why did you stop looking for me
John it was kits idea I don't know
whether he ever will come back I hope he
does I love I love benjin I think I just
got you know distracted busy I think we
came for yeah maybe one more yes hello
you this is my sexy in great costume you
look amazing
thank you a little cold north of the
wall we're in that door I figured this
is angry in the cave I simply remember
Ingrid the cave weren't wearing much of
anything at all as I I just wanted to
come up and say thank you for creating
such an amazing show and books it gives
us a fantasy to take home that is a
little bit more real so my mom back here
and I wanted to come and say thank you
for everything thank you thank you thank
you
let's take one more we could do one more
coming up that was a lovely question
though hello Oh
I had a question about a difference that
the shell took from the book in the show
I'm not gonna ruin it for anybody don't
worry but in the show when Jamie
releases Tyrion it's kind of a short
scene but in the book he had an exchange
with Syria and that really changed the
dynamic of the relationship and I was
wondering what was the creative reasons
behind the omission of that scene well
that's that's got to be for you guys I
think although I have to as someone
before they even answer I think that
that that relationship was established
in numerous scenes leading up to the
point least that's what I thought watch
and I was like no I get it I get that
it's changed but what do you think you
know I think I think sometimes in an
adaptation from a book there are certain
things you're gonna lose and one of the
problems is we don't have access to the
characters mind so there's an amazing
relation there's an amazing backstory
for Tyrion which we learn about
basically because we're inside Tyrion
skull and we have pages and pages where
we learn exactly what happened and it's
a really powerful moment of the story
the problem is the only way for us to do
it in the show would be either through
dialogue or through action we're not
gonna have a flashback showing that
scene we haven't had any flashbacks yet
and we didn't want to have voiceover so
unless we had a long scene with dialogue
explaining what happened all those years
ago which just felt like it wasn't gonna
work that was something that went by the
wayside and there are all sorts of these
at these cuts that are incredibly
difficult for us because oftentimes
they're they're bits from the books that
we love the most and for whatever reason
it just doesn't seem to work on scream
when we've got five hundred and forty
minutes to tell a whole season and just
you know this kind of goes at
hand-in-hand with the call before for
extra episodes believe us from a
storytelling point of view we'd love to
have 13 episodes that would be fantastic
the problem is the the problem is we
can't we actually we finished
post-production and we've already
started up post pre-production on the
next season and we there's there's
absolutely no downtime between the end
of one season the start of the next
there's just no time for us to shoot
more episodes and maintain the kind of
quality in terms of production value
going all the different countries and
getting the
locations having the visual effects guys
create the Dragons all that stuff so
less we find some really good divorce
lawyers it's not gonna help you either I
speak from some experience just do what
you need to do I think that's you know
and George said before read the books I
think it's one that one of the things
that we always hope is that people who
haven't read the books but watch the
show then might be drawn to the books
which we think is true for a lot of
people and then they can learn a lot
more about these characters than they
ever would watching the show alone and
and get much more depth and time to
spend with those characters and learn
all about them so unfortunately as hard
as we try we can't possibly match the
the amount of detail and and
storytelling in a twelve hundred page
book over the course of the season and
and I guess the last thing I would say
is that when we first talked to George
when we first got the books they were
sent to us to adapt as feature films and
the idea was that each book would be one
feature so if you can imagine that Game
of Thrones as a two and half hour movie
just think about everything that would
have been that would have been mutilated
and cut out of that story and one of the
reasons we really wanted to do this as a
show and luckily George agreed with us
was even though we couldn't have
everything at least we could have ten
hours for each of those books and in the
case of Storm of Swords 20 hours and
even then you know we're amazed to find
out how much of the of the detail we
just can't get in there so I think it
was I'm always reminded I think it was
Jim Thompson the great crime novelist
who had a reporter asked him how do you
feel about what Hollywood has done to
your books and he pointed to his
bookshelf and he said Hollywood hasn't
done anything to my books they're right
there books are always going to be their
own pristine that's world point and
which books existed will always exist
they sure exist and it will always exist
thank you so much to you guys for
showing up and to you guys as an
audience member and a fan of the show
thank you so much for coming to San
Diego thank you
[Applause]
you